earlier this morning we were fortunate
to have Kim mana he from no two very
conductive blessing for Rohit anitha and
thank you kim very much for doing so we
greatly appreciate that shortly will be
addressed by three speakers Robin
Wallace the chair of kaiapoi community
board Matt dulce member of parliament
for Waimakariri and David ears mayor of
Wye McCreery who will then officially
open the center just as the new
playground intrusive a park has bought
the laughter and vitality of our
tamariki and Planetary to the town
center so to brew a ton Aoife will offer
a place to meet in loom a place for
everyone in a fabulous addition to our
community like Blackwell's and teresa
low park this new building is a great
anchor project for the renewal of
kaiapoi and for the recovery
yah
Oh God
it's a great day for why Makka really
because cowboy is one of our two main
towns and it's important for the whole
district that cowboy is doing well and
it's a great day for kaiapoi because it
marks a new stage in the history of this
great town rua tanofir was an otaku
settlement near the confluence that we
now know as the cam and cowboy rivers
and effect ruined tanofir which also
uses a name for one of the names used
for the cam river it was a place from
which food was gathered in the local
rivers and wetlands and of course the
area we are now sitting on the name
reflects the history of this area in the
continuity of community and we are
grateful to tonight to hurry Runanga for
gifting the name to us as the original
route an affair was a place where people
came together to fish to hunt and gather
food may the Civic Center also be a
place where people come together for
productive purpose
Oh
help us explore and enjoy
Oh